the astros taking on the blue jays
christian javier is on the bump for the
houston astros
quick peek at his numbers this year five
starts this season a 1.75 era putting up
great numbers with a whiff under one
swing and a miss javier starts tonight
with a strikeout as he gets simeon
call third strike javier
back-to-back strikeouts freezes bo
buchet how about that way to start the
game
and that when the bray you missed on a
couple of strikes that should have been
called miles strong got a good jump on
that ball of the ban of guerrero and
tracks it down on the warning track so a
one two three start for christian javier
they will face steven matt's making his
seventh start and going for his fifth
win he's been hit hard lately in his
last two starts 11 earned runs on 15
hits covering just eight and two-thirds
innings
from these righties threw a good curve
ball down and away there when he strikes
out altouve one down
a bouncer to third big hop for biggio he
pulls vlady off the bag but guerrero
sticks with it to make the tag two down
how about stephen mats
inside corner with a fastball strike
three called a terrific first inning for
mats
off to a great start tonight needing 10
pitches in the first inning this ball
hit to left field diaz near the wall he
leaps up and he makes the play
diaz had the gauge the wind and the out
of town scoreboard
and he makes the play leaping in
to the wall for out number one on te
oscar hernandez
so here's kevin biggio playing in the
ballpark that he grew up in when his dad
was playing there
first pitch swinging and a high drive
deep right field it is gone a two-run
homer for kevin biggio on the first
pitch that he sees and yeah dad might
work for the astros but he's got a big
smile on his face right now doesn't he
felt like they were really trying to get
ahead of him early in the count with
fastballs and he said you know what i've
got to start being a little bit more
aggressive early in the count i can't
let these
fastballs go by and he didn't let that
one go by keep the ball on the plate
where he needs to
2-2 and how about that curveball
swinging a miss one down
finds the ball to left field but on to
make the catch is his little brother how
about that lourdes will have
uh the last laugh at least for now
correa with a fly ball to center field
grichik there six up six down so far for
steven matt's chance in with a home run
in each of his last two games
as jansen lifts one high and deep to
left field and it is gone
danny jansen with his third home run in
his many games some much needed offense
a little bit of a smile round in the
bases for danny and it is three to
nothing
and that was a no doubt about her right
there told you that christian javier
doesn't give up many home runs while
he's giving up two now randall grichik
coming up now grichik walked and scored
on the biggio home run in the second
inning
and the 01 hit in the air left center
field
it is deep and it is off the wall coming
in to score is simeon heading for home
is guerrero and grichik has done it
again a two-run double to extend the
lead to five to nothing he's making
mistakes with his slider this inning he
hasn't been able to throw for a strike
team struck out swinging his first time
up
altuve with a base hit into left field
that'll push maldonado over to second
base astros have something going against
steven matz finally after he retired the
first eight batter
got some pop 18 home runs as a blue jay
three years ago
and a soft liner back to the mound
speared by matz and that will end the
inning
here's the 2-2
and that one's club
left field pretty deep going back on it
is guriel and he's going to have to play
it off the
wall bregman into second base with the
lead-off double
so bregman on second base for alvarez
he's over one here's the one one
and this one's the other way this one's
deep
what'd you expect
jordan alvarez's sixth home run of the
season it's five to two
and his third in the last three games
bringing the astros back down three now
this is how strong he actually is
just clips it enough to get it into that
crawford box
there's a base hit to right field alex
bregman
finds a hole in the right side and that
will bring the tying run to the plate
and your don alvarez in the fifth inning
an extended inning here for steven matz
2-2 little lock ball into center field
that's going to drop for a hit jordan
gets one off the end of the bat and it
falls in for a single to center
into score let miss diaz
give him another rbi three on the night
and the astros within two now
and looks like he will lazy fly ball to
left field guriel drifting into the
alley makes the catch one down
[Music]
bouncing ball to short boy a tough hop
the ball didn't come up for bushette and
he still makes the play to get him two
down
another ground ball this time for biggio
and six up six down for tyler chatwood
in the beginning of the year was going
to be julian merriweather getting some
saves here's bregman hooking one into
left field that'll be down for a hit
gauriel can't quite make the play
cleanly so bregman will get into second
he's got a lead off double for the
astros here in the eighth
and alex bregman gets to third we're
gonna bring up julie guriel
on the ground infield back bregman will
score easily but shet makes the play in
time to get curiel that'll be an rbi for
yuli two outs in the inning it's now a
five to four game
little tapper back to raley checks the
runner at third goes to first
they get the out there curiel jr moves
into
scoring position in the second base with
one out
2-2
simeon reaches for it sends a fly ball
to left and it's gone
marcus simeon with a three-run homer
and that's the insurance the blue jays
were looking for it's now eight to four
and he's got joe smith talking to
himself how about the big hits that
marcus simeon has come up with on this
road trip alone
and the one two
jammed him a fly ball to shallow right
down the line and to oscar is there to
make a nice running catch
and secure the victory the blue jays
start fash fast finished strong and beat
the astros eight to four to even up the
series at a win a peace